Apple pay has forever changed the way we  pay for things and it's gotten off to  the most amazing start and has enormous  momentum we started with just six banks  in the u.s. they were the largest banks  it was a fantastic start but now we have  over 2500 banks supporting apple pay we  started with a great list of retailer  partners but now in just three months  later we've tripled the number of  locations that are accepting Apple pay  to nearly 700,000 across the u.s. and  one of the really cool and convenient  places that that has come up out of  Apple pay our vending machines coca-cola  now has 40,000 of these in the US and  plans to have a hundred thousand by the  end of the year so if you're like me  you've stood in front of those machines  too many times trying to uncritical your  dollar bill and get it to be recognized  those days are over